your daughter
Nick Cannon closing out 2022 with one
more bundle of joy the stork is on the
way we'll see how it trickles down the
mass singer host and Alyssa Scott are
proud parents of their second child
together a daughter Halo Marie Cannon
the model shares the happy news to
Instagram taking fans inside the
delivery room Alyssa writes quote our
lives are forever changed
yes
and she reflects on a solemn Milestone
the new arrival comes one year after the
tragic loss of their five-month-old son
Zen from brain cancer Alyssa says quote
Zen is in every breath I take and she
will always remember the sound of Nick's
voice saying it's a girl and the look of
everything we've been through flashed
across his face maybe you would have
another baby with Alyssa you never know
it's one of those things where we're
optimistic in the process yep that was
Nick playing Coy in July while
co-hosting E.T in the Bahamas kids you
know I got a lot of them yeah let's do
some math Halos baby number 12 for Nick
and also the fifth child he's welcomed
this year meanwhile Hollywood's not
afraid to crack a few jokes I know Nick
is tired he's been up all night
memorizing his kids names oh
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa while
the rappering comedian isn't shy about
loving fatherhood my children have
busier schedules than I do he did admit
there's drawbacks on the checkup with Dr
David agus being the father of multiple
kids it's always you know the biggest
guilt on on music I don't get us get to
spend enough time with all of my
children one because I'm constantly
working and two just just spread thin so
what's on the docket for 2023 it's
anyone's guess but last month Nick told
billboard news he's not sure if he'll
have any more kids I don't know man I
have no idea hello I think I'm good
right now though
[Music]